un bulletin et blanc lorsque les
lecteurs lis dans l' enveloppe un papier
blanc sans aucun ans ou quand il vote
avec une enveloppe vide
le vote blanc une démarche électorales
récurrentes
pourtant elle n'a aucun poids sur
l'issue du scrutin ces bulletins vierges
ne sont pas comptabilisés dans les
suffrages exprimés et c'est ce que
dénonçait déjà gérard gautier dans les
années 90
actuellement le vote blanc n'est pas
reconnue c'est à dire que quand les gens
votent blanc c'est-à-dire font la
démarche d'aller à l'urne ce qui est
déjà important ça démontre une volonté
civique de participer à la vie du pays
et bien leur vote leur suffrage est
assimilé au vote nul au même titre que
quelqu'un qui mur qui ratures au crayon
ou quoi que ce soit sur son butin ce
n'est pas sain pour une démocratie
pour gérard gautier communicants de
profession blanc s'est exprimé c'est
d'ailleurs le nom de son mouvement créé
en 1989
son but la reconnaissance du vote blanc
peut-être que le fait de voir le vote
blanc reconnu comme étant un suffrage
exprimé va faire prendre conscience aux
hommes politiques qu'ils n'ont pas à
quel ont eux aussi à être sanctionné
quand il le faut et ça leur fera peut
être changer de façon de faire mais la
prise de conscience politique a du mal à
prendre après 1993 une quarantaine de
propositions de loi sont déposées sur le
sujet en vain à voter alors dans les
années 2000 le combat continue pour les
défenseurs du vote blanc d'autres
mouvements voit le jour jusqu'à cette
loi votée en 2013
la reconnaissance du vote blanc fait
l'unanimité à l'assemblée nationale les
députés l'ont adopté aujourd'hui c'est
l'idée y le parti de jean-louis borloo
qui a défendu cette mesure vous aviez
deux candidats trois candidats ça vous
convenait pas vous pouviez pas
l'exprimer maintenant tout le monde
vraiment aller voter et compris le vote
blanc je pense que cette année une
avancée démocratique majeur dorénavant
les bulletins blancs sont différenciés
des bulletins nuls ceux qui sont raturé
ou déchirer pour autant ils ne sont
toujours pas comptabilisés dans les
suffrages exprimés
victoire en demi-teinte donc pour les
militants surtout pour ceux de la
première heure la loi a été voté qui
fait rentrer en compte ses parts au
niveau de leur comptabilisation les
votes blancs des votes nuls sans pour
autant leur donner légitimité d'un
suffrage exprimé en 2015 la porte parole
des citoyens du vote blanc allait plus
loin pour elle les raisons de la non
reconnaissance de ce vote était clair si
le vote blanc étaient comptabilisés
parmi les suffrages exprimés aujourd'hui
très clairement il pourrait invalider
une élection et c'est pour ça que ça
pose problème
effectivement un vote blanc comptabilisé
modifierait les seuils électoraux
nécessaire pour atteindre la majorité
absolue condition sinequanone pour être
élu fin mars un sondage révélait que
pour 66 % des français le vote blanc
devait être prise en compte
[Musique]